the US has an epidemic on its hands
peanut allergies between 1997 and 2008
the number of American children with a
peanut allergy has tripled and today an
estimated 1.8 million kids in the US
have one that's larger than the entire
population of Philadelphia and the u.s.
is not alone the UK Canada and Australia
have seen a similar rise in child peanut
allergies but that's not the case for
other countries like China Thailand
Korea the Philippines and Israel so what
these countries have that the US doesn't
in Israel there's a joke that the first
three words out of every toddlers mouth
are ABBA which means dad i'muh which
means mom and bomba bomba is a popular
peanutty snack an estimated 90% of
Israeli families buy it on a regular
basis and guess what the peanut allergy
rate in Israel is one-tenth the rate
that it is in the UK and in China and
Thailand many children eat peanut rice
porridge for breakfast and wouldn't you
know it peanut allergies are relatively
low there too but this could be a
coincidence right thank goodness we have
the researchers at King's College London
they recruited 640 infants four to ten
months old who were at risk of
developing a peanut allergy half of the
kids in the study ate peanut snacks
regularly whereas the other half were
told to avoid peanuts entirely then when
the kids were 5 years old they were
brought in for one final experiment all
of them were instructed to eat some type
of peanut protein of the kids who ate
peanut snacks regularly since infancy
3.2 percent had developed a peanut
allergy but the kids who avoided peanuts
all together were much worse off
more than 17 percent of them had
developed an allergy to a nut that they
had never consumed that means there were
six times more likely to develop a
peanut allergy than kids who regularly
ate peanuts now of course this is just
one study but if you know how allergies
work it begins to make sense when
someone with a peanut allergy encounters
a peanut for the first time their immune
system kicks into overdrive in this case
it ceased the peanut as a threat and it
produces antibodies in anticipation for
a future encounter so the next time this
person eats a peanut antibodies activate
an immune response which the person
experiences as an allergic reaction
scientists aren't sure why some people
experience reactions and others don't
but they think that early exposure can
certainly help at-risk infants and
luckily allergies aren't always set in
stone in a clinical trial earlier this
year
doctors recruited children with peanut
allergies they gave them a small dose of
peanut powder and slowly increased the
dose over time
sure enough the children's immune
systems became accustomed to the powder
and nearly all of them were able to
build up a tolerance to it this process
called desensitization is a way of
tricking your immune system and it could
if used correctly and safely become a
way to treat children who have a mild
reaction to peanuts and although results
have been promising so far these
treatments are not a cure what's more
scientists suspect that genetics may
also play a role in allergy development
so before you take matters into your own
hands and start feeding your babies
peanuts talk to a doctor and make sure
that you're in the clear
after all like everything in life
peanuts should be enjoyed in moderation
[Music]